[Musique]
quel bonheur de vous retrouver pour au
bonheur des livres avec deux écrivains
Victor dumiaot 27 ans acide rentrée
littéraire Victor bonjour c'est un livre
dont on va beaucoup parler et vous êtes
accompagné de Denis dercour donc qui
publie hvreux qui est un roman chez de
Noël Denis a 59 ans il est à la fois
musicien cinéaste et c'est aussi son
premier roman Le malâ est un des grands
sujets de la littérature vous le savez
ça c'est banal de citer dostoyevski et
beaucoup d'autres mais c'est un peu le
sujet de vos deux livres qui sont deux
livres écrits à l' c'est deux livres
c'est pour ça que nous avons choisi avec
la rédaction au bonheur des livres qui
ne sont pas là pour draguer le lecteur
ni même pour draguer la critique qui
sont là tout simplement parce qu'ils
s'inscrivent dans un parcours cours qui
est celui de la littérature que vous
aimez on va commencer par vous Victor du
d'abord je vous salue parce que ça je fa
alors Victor vous êtes vous êtes
normalien ce qui n'est pas un défaut
d'une certaine manière vous pourriez
être à la place de Bruno LEM dans
quelques années de la même manière que
Denis pourrait être une sorte de barenby
et pourtant vous êtes tous les deux au
chevet de la littérature avec un premier
roman est-ce que ça a été compliqué pour
vous de prendre cette décision et l'un
et l'autre d'écrire un premier roman bah
c'est c'est c'est une sorte d'aventure
enfin c'est c'est une prise de risque
déjà il y a le le fait de de d'être
publié puis surtout le le choix du sujet
aussi c'est pour ça que j'ai
personnellement choisi un sujet assez
difficile parce que je voulais que ce
soit un vrai un vrai Paris un vrai un
vrai voilà et puis un coup de point il
faut le dire et puis un vrai coup de
point un vrai coup de point Denis quand
on a une carrière avec une dizaine de
films vous avez été altiste tout à
l'heure je disais avec humour vous êtes
aussi dans une famille où il y a à la
fois les producteur de cinéma et en même
temps les gens qui font de la musique
pourquoi avoir attendu toutes ces années
pour pour pour pour écrire un premier
rment après avoir écrit nombre de
scénarios parce que j'y arrivais pas
parce que ça a mis 30 ans et ensuite
c'est difficile d'écrire un livre donc
c'est 3 années donc c'est 33 ans
finalement mais maintenant je pense que
le roman permet de dire des choses que
ni la musique ni le cinéma peuvent dire
pour quelle raison euh le travail du
temps est extra ire dans le roman je
trouve c'est vraiment le le lieu le le
plus extraordinaire pour travailler le
passage du temps peut-être pour des
moyens physiques hein c'est difficile de
de traverser 50 person années d'un
personnage ou d'une ville et là on le
fait voilà hvre raconte effectivement
l'histoire d'un certain nombre de
personnages tout ça est marqué par le
mal entre cette période effrayante que
fut évidemment l'occupation jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est publié chez de Noël
nous allons y revenir et commencer par
Victor parce que Victor vous êtes le
plus jeune donc vous avez cet avantage
nous nous aimons les gens qui sortent
justement de l'anonymat dans Au Bonheur
des livres de quoi s'agit-il et bien
c'est tout simplement résumé je veux
dire assiné dès la première page de ce
livre j'avais un visage mais il me fut
pris c'est pas une commodité de ma part
mais par que c'est une volonté de la
vôre d'avoir commencé par ça c'est
arrivé un soir un soir que je pensais
comme les autres que je croyais léger un
ciel tranquille noir endormi siendait
a-dessus de ma tête j'aurais dû me
méfier évidemment camille est une jeune
femme qui a 27 ans elle met une robe
verte elle va sortir à Saint-Germain
Despré et là brutalement dans un cri
sort du néant quelqu'un qui doit être un
homme mais on en est pas sûr et qui la
vitriolise absolument oui oui pour moi
il était important de commencer
directement en fait d'entrer directement
dans le vif de de ce qu'allait être ce
roman euh de ne pas prendre le temps de
décrire Camille dans sa vie dans son
environnement voilà de commencer par un
acte très fort la scène se s'étend sur
une dizaine de pages la souffrance est
atroce perd son visage la souffrance est
atroce voilà ce qui ce qui ce qui
m'intéressait c'était de de travailler
l'expérience de la douleur d'abord la
douleur physique puis psychologique
l'effondrement véritablement intérieur
enfin parce que la particularité de
l'acide c'est que c'est un c'est un
processus chimique ce sont commme des
vers qui qui son qui s'insinuent dans
votre peau et qui vous qui vous gr elle
le sent d'ailleurs elle le ressent dès
le début elle a l'impression de l'eau
puis elle se sent complètement non
seulement défiguré mais mais ravagé de
l'intérieur
la douleur est absolument atroce et puis
a ce personnage qu'on ne connaît pas et
il y a un autre personnage qui construit
le livre puisquil y a une sorte de de
face à face qui est un un jeune homme
qui vit dans un studio dans un
appartement et qui se comment on peut
dire qui se nourrit sur le Darknet de
vidéo porno et qui se nourrit justement
de la vidéo de l'agression de Camille et
c'est la confrontation entre les deux
qui construit le livre absolument deux
deux monstres en fait deux monstres
contant pour un Camille devient
monstrueuse puisqu'elle est défigurée
euh elle est exclue en fait du du
domaine parce per perdre son visage
évidemment c'est perdre son identité
c'est perdre c'est paraître aux yeux du
monde comme un comme un comme un monstre
comme une comme un monstre comme une
victime aussi ce qui peut être
extrêmement dur à supporter d'être
d'être vu et perçu comme comme comme une
victime et Julien c'est le monstre
contemporain c'est la c'est la banalité
de ce mal là contemporain c'est un jeune
homme ça pourrait être moi ça pourrait
être n'importe qui euh Camille et Julien
sont de la même génération c'estàd que
c'est cette génération de l'image aussi
tous les deux sont euh plus ou moins
enfermés dans une dans de dans un
certain nombre de représentations
mentales qui les qui les détruisent et
et et et Julien effectivement se nourrit
en fait il il consomme de manière très
addictive euh une pornographie de plus
en plus violente d'ailleurs on est même
plus dans le domaine de la pornographie
c'est-à-dire que ce qu'il ce qui
l'intéresse c'est la c'est la c'est la
violence c'est la vérité de la violence
si nous les avons choisis tous les deux
c'est justement par la force incroyable
de ces deux livres celui qui a mis des
années à arriver celui de Denis et celui
qui a j celui de Victor car je le disais
au départ ce sont des livres qui ne sont
pas psychologiques qui ne draguent pas
c'est qu' ne sont pas à la recherche
l'une tradition littéraire formidable
d'ailleurs en France les fleurs du malâ
mémoire d'retombe là c'est acide éévreux
c'est qu'on y va directement et et et et
donc ce qui je reste avec vous Victor ce
face à face se construit car on se doute
au début du livre et ça va passionner
aussi qu'à un moment ou un autre ils
vont se rencontrer sans qu'on sache si
Julien est l'agresseur ou si l'esclave
de cette femme totalement défigurée qui
en veut à ses médecin qui en veut à ses
chirurgiens et qui à un moment va être
obligé après l'anesthésie de l'hôpital
car l'hôpital c'est une forme
d'anesthésie de faire l'expérience à un
moment de se découvrir face à la glace
pour savoir qui elle est aujourd'hui oui
oui oui oui c'est c'est scène effrayante
ti à vous le dire c'est effectivement
une une la confrontation je j'ai j'ai
découvert littérature par le thriller
donc j'ai été très très imprégé en fait
de cette tradition là du roman noir du
suspense et je pense qu'à notre à notre
époque où la le temps consacré à lecture
est de plus en plus réduit où il est
difficile de capturer l'attention de de
lecteur les dispositifs narratifs du
thriller les dispositifs narratifs du de
diverement sthan King polici comme oui
alors moi je disisais plutôt
Jean-Christophe Granger c'était vraiment
voilà c'estation pardonar exactement et
qui écrit d'ailleurs assez bien euh et
donc voilà en fait je voulais
effectivement construire le le livre est
construit sous la forme d'un compte à
rebour d'ailleurs donc on a cette cette
impression c'est un piège en fait
puisque il n a absolument rien du
thriller dans ce dans ce roman au au
infin mais mais c'est un piège il y a
plusieurs pièges dans ce livre il y a le
piège de d'encore un récit victimaire on
est quand même à une époque où le où la
la littérature s'engage de plus en plus
sur le le témoignage et et et c'était
aussi le le le point de départ de ce
roman c'était prendre encore une femme
victime de quelque chose et et est
complètement détournée cette chose la
rendre plus humaine je je disais tout à
l'heure Victor que l'une des
caractéristiques justement par rapport à
cette vague de récit victimaire ce n'est
pas à moi de de juger ces livres qui
pour leurs auteurs ont une nécessité
mais ce qui est intéressant dans le
point de vue de Victor c'est que Camille
n'est pas ce qu'on peut appeler une
jeune femme profondément sympathique
c'estàd qu'elle est jolie elle est
diplômée et elle sait que ces deux
qualités vont jouer dans sa vie sociale
un rôle déterminant quand elle va sortir
le soir c'est déjà quelqu'un qui a qui a
vaincu la société sauf que brutalement
c'est elle qui va devenir la victime et
elle entre dans un processus qui est un
processus de survie et non pas de
plainte absolument c'était en fait voilà
la grande question que posait ce roman
en tout cas pour le personnages de
Camille comment est-ce qu'on a comment
est-ce qu'on peut sortir de la condition
de victime c'est une condition qui c'est
cette une assignation presque
identitaire un remplacement de sa propre
identité par ce statut qui est très
dégradant quand on est victime on a subi
un rapport de force et même si on se on
se libère en témoignant on reste une
victime aux yeux des autres et le
personnage de Camille est construit
comme l'antithèse de la victime c'est
une femme qui est effectivement méchante
désagréable et qui est en fait plus
humaine grâce à cela c'est c'est voilà
c'est c'est c'est une femme aussi un peu
un peu superficielle qui redécouvre
l'étendue de sa superficialité qui
repense sa vie en il y a un trajet
introspectif et il y a des moments qui
sont alors ce qui est très étonnant dans
ce livre ce n'est pas un accè de
gornerie c'est qu'au fond ça pourrait
paraître simple une femme est victime
d'une agression atroce on ne sait pas
qui est l'agresseur se présente un jeune
homme qui a tous les aspects de
l'agresseur mais qui n'est peut-être pas
l'agresseur et donc on dit tout ça va
être réglé assez facilement et ça ne
l'est pas car au fond il y a toute la
reconstruction de Camille comme non
victime elle se plaint auprès de ses
médecins elle croit qu'avec les mois
passés à l'hôpital cette espèce d'écorse
d'arbre qui est devenu son visage va
finir par retrouver une forme mais elle
ne retrouve pas cette forme lui c'est un
malade il y a pas d'autre mot c'est
c'est c'est un type qui se torture
lui-même qui est sur le Darknet qui
appelle des gens pour se faire torturer
donc vous avez quand même choisi pour un
normalien une version de la littérature
qui est tout sauf on on on on n'est pas
chez les enfants de borisian non pas
vraiment mais c'est parce que voilà moi
je pense que le la littérature peut
retrouver sa puissance si elle devient
dérangeante je tiens je tiens beaucoup à
à cette notion de de dérangement à la
notion de corruption aussi du lecteur
enfin euh le statut de de l'auteur
aujourd'hui inquiè beaucoup les gens qui
lisent puisqu'on ne dissocie plus le le
texte donc il faut en profiter je pense
il faut il faut en profiter il faut
inquiéter de plus en plus les lecteurs
pour les les amener à se questionner
eux-mêmees à réfléchir moi je je pense
que le le choc que peut produire un un
livre amène beaucoup plus de de de de de
de questionnement que de que de répones
on on ne doit on ne peut pas offrir au
lecteurs des des réponses très très
précises et exactes en revanche on peut
l'interroger l'amener à s'interroger et
je pense que la littérature qui dérange
est un
euh l'autre caractéristique de ce
premier roman de Victor duumot on sent
qu'il y en a d'autres qui sont déjà
partis c'est la qualité du style car
effectivement pour tenir 200 sur un
sujet pareil il pourrait être facile de
srer dans le grand diloquant dans le
démonstratif ce n'est absolument pas le
cas jusqu'à cette rencontre de la fin
car Julien veut rencontrer Camille qui
veut rencontrer Julien et je ne vais pas
tout dévoiler car ça n'a aucun intérêt
mais je ne peux pas m'empêcher quand
même je ne peux pas m'en empêcher voilà
donc Julien se dit Camille pas vraiment
impressionnant moins impressionnant que
devant sa webcam moins impressionnant
qu'au travers de ses mots délirants il
est pauvre désevent trop nu le reste
c'est à lire bien évidemment et c'est le
livre de Victor dumot qui s'appelle
acide au fond il y a quand même une
volonté d'être écrivain tout d'un coup
vous êtes normalien vous auriez pu être
éar vous auriez pu faire une carrière
politique vous avez dit non je veux être
écrivain pourquoi et est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose d'autobiographique dans
cette affaire ou pas du tout soyons Fran
je peux d'abord répondre à la première
partie cette question non non je j'ai
toujours écrit mais je n'ai jamais cru
que mon écriture deviendrait
professionnelle enfin je pensais que je
pas d'être édité un jour ça ne
m'arriverait jamais et puis et puis
quand voilà il y a des moments où il
faut il faut oser rompre rompre avec une
certaine facilité avec un une volonté
d'embourgeoisement aussi donc rompre
avec lesenard rompre avec le ns rompre
avec tout ça écrire et puis prendre un
risque et c'est comme ça qu' ass des nez
et il n a il y a il y a une part
biographique c'est une sorte de de fable
métaphorique je suis plus présent dans
Camille que dans Julien c'est pas
paradoxalement voilà c livre qu'il faut
lire et qui a été récompensé par le prix
de la Maison rouge à Biaritz qui est un
prix décerné par des écrivains confirmés
puisquil y a Frédéric bbéé Philippe Dian
mais aussi Isabelle luper beaucoup
d'autres membres Frédéric siifter qui se
sont battus pour vous et pour que ce
livre trouve un écho Denis Dercourt
publie Évreux qui est en roman chez la
différence Denis puisqueon disait tout à
l'heure au début de l'émission qu'avec
vous deux on va traiter du mal c'est que
c'est le mal contemporain à la fois la
violence et le Darknet vous c'est un mal
qui provient de l'histoire je vous
rappelle que vous êtes musicien aussi
qu'on connaît en 44 et que ça va jusqu'à
2020 et qui a cette idée que le livre se
construit un peu comme une partition à
la fois historique et
musicale je résume c'est une jeune
femme qui est confrontée à la naissance
d'un enfant sous l'Occupation euh dans
des conditions qui sont évidemment
apocalyptiques
euh et et c'est là que que démarre le
livre et que démarre donc la carrière du
personnage central qui est Léon Léon qui
est comment peut-on dire qui est le
héros infréquentable par définition non
et et c'est pour ça qu'il est fascinant
c'est en fait c'est le fils de sa mère
donc victime de de sorte de viol
collectif de et de et de son père qui
qui qui a vendu la mère quand il était
jeune fille et donc s'appelle mer c'est
qui était un belge il est le le père est
belge et il a été
collaborateur et assez vite la mère
quand Léon grandit lui dit ben tu me
vengeras si tu retrouves ton père tu le
tues et et ce qui me semblait
intéressant c'est que il va le faire il
va obéir à sa mère mais avec les
méthodes de son père en fait il il est
le fils de sa mère d'une victime mais il
est aussi le fils d'un bourreau et
lui-même est dans dans ce statut gris
ambigu intéressant en fait c'est et du
coup c'est des figures du mal évidemment
mais qu'on qu'on a envie de suivre moi
moi au départ c'était une figure mineure
en fait et puis peu à peu le roman s'est
construit et puis c'est c'est lui qui
m'a fasciné un peu comme l'enfant
audessus du puit c'est tellement profond
on reste au-dessus du puit pour savoir
mais jusqu'où ça va alors ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que dès le
départ c'est un homme sans pitié je veux
dire par là qu'il va à la chasse comme
rabatteur quelqu'un se suicide devant
lui pas de pitié il prend son
portefeuille on verra que ce
portefeuille joue un rôle parce que ça
lui permettra de de retrouver un fils
c'est aussi un un un homme qui
s'approprie une entreprise en faisant
chanter son propriétaire en disant qu'il
va dans les hôtels de pass on est
toujours dans le contexte d'Évreux et de
cette Normandie autour de laquelle vous
tournez c'est aussi un homme qui arrache
une jeune fille qu' désire à une famille
en faisant chanter là oussil perère le
sa famille je la prends d'Ille il va la
rejeter plus tard au profit d'une
manouche mais en faisant chantter le
père à aucun moment il est habité par le
moindre remord de ses origines et de son
action absolument le le mais c'est un
homme qui par exemple aime la musique
donc quand on aime la musique on n'est
pas TS enfin il y a au moins une part de
rédemption possible en ça c'est vous
peut-être ouais vous avez voulu lui
donner justement cette part qui lui
donne un aspect acceptable pour les gens
qui lisent et qui vont lire avreux bah
parce que c'est sinon c'est un
portemanteau d'une idée je pense pas que
écrire un roman ce soit donner des idées
c'est c'est donner des personnages des
situations et puis c'est vous dites il y
a pas de psychologie oui effectivement
il y a pas de psychologie mais dans mais
mais parce que il y a beaucoup de
psychologie mais c'est le lecteur qui
fait la psychologie c'est le lecteur qui
va faire l'interprétationation aussi qui
l'a fait oui exactement parce qu'on est
dans un une mère un père atroce ce
flamand qui justement collabore avec les
nazis et corrom absolument tout le monde
le fils qui qui va le
tuer parce que sa mère lui demande mais
qui est lui aussi une certaine forme de
figure du salot on est dans la grande
tradition de la littérature on parlait
de dostoyevski tout à l'heure on
pourrait parler il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont intéressés au mal anabokov et
cetera et cetera et cetera et ce qui m'a
intéressé aussi au fur et à mesure des
années c'est la façon dont tout ça
corrom toutes les filiations des
personnages différents c'est que tous
ceux qui naissent de cette avant
autour d'Évreux sont tous finalement
corrompus par cette idée du départ qui
est celle de la collaboration et de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ben c'est un des
un des grands mystères du mal parce que
le mal est lui-même un mystère mais mais
il va avoir des effets qui qui ne
s'arrêtent pas et évidemment l'ffet de
la culpabilité aussi hein c'est donc
c'est après il y a des nouvelles
générations qui arrivent et qui
heureusement sortent de cette mais
lentement lentement oui parce que lui
Léon euh il est à la fois horticulteur
euh propriétaire d'hôtel proenet
euh
violent il y a pas d'autres mot tendre
avec sa mère mais
violent avec tous les autres en
préparant cette émission avec toute
l'équipe je me suis dit c'est assez
amusant parce que vous êtes cinéaste
Denis mais j'ai l'impression de recevoir
à vous deux euh Martine scorz c'estàdire
que d'un côté euh Victor ce serait Taxi
Driver euh c'est à Trevor beckles le
rôle célèbre De Niro je suppose que vous
aimez et de l'autre côté Denis ce serait
tous les autres c'est-à-dire à la fois
casino Gangs of Tork euh c'est-à-dire
une dans ces deux visions du mal il y a
le type possédé par le mal et vous c'est
le mal construit par l'histoire est-ce
que j'ai tort ou raison évidemment c'est
une flagornerie à trance de ma part mais
c'est pas si mal que çaag non mais je je
vais défausser en disant qu'il a des
acteurs exceptionnels scorsais et et je
pense que nous notre notre trôle de
romancier c'est aussi de mettre des
figures qui sont à la hauteur de de ces
acteurs ce qui est très impressionnant
quand on dirige des acteurs c'est que
les acteurs parce que vous avez fait une
dizaine de films voà et les acteurs
eux-mêmes adorent jouer des méchants
voilà alors pourquoi ça c'est un mystère
mais ils adorent ça et nous notre job de
cinas mais aussi de romancier c'est
comme disent les Américains the better
the villain plus le méchant est réussi
plus le film est réussi ce qui est le
cas quand même chez corsaz si on parle
de d'apocalypse de la violence
je vais donner un certain nombre et et
de mélange parce que c'est ça qui commun
à vos deux livres parce que c'est
intéressant de c'est qu' il y a quand
même un lien Victor et et Denis entre la
violence et la sexualité c'est clair
dans acide et c'est aussi clair dans
hévreux bien sûr oui oui et puis encore
une fois c'est c'est une grande
problématique de notre époque
c'està-dire qu'on interroge de plus en
plus la sexualité à l'Ô de la violence
au travers de la notion de consentement
par exemple mais mais moi moi qui ai
grandi avec George bataille enfin elle
est déjà là elle a toujours été là cette
question de de l'érotisme noir du désir
de la violence d'un désir aussi donc oui
oui moi c'est c'est en tout cas c'est
aussi ce que ce quiessit de travailler
acide en profondeur la figure du mal
violent et obsédé par une sexualité qui
est elle-même des g et c'est l'anti
poliitiquement correct absolu parce
qu'aujourd'hui justement ce qu'on essaie
c'est de séparer les deux absolument
c'est que la sexualité sera une certaine
forme de bonheur et n'aurait aucun
rapport avec le mal alors c'est
exactement le contraire de ce qui se
passe dans vos deux romans Julien euh il
y a pas d'autrre mot hein il se masturbe
de ces vidéos atroces qu'il reçoit et et
lui Léon il fait son choix parmi les
jeunes femmes qui passent qu'elle soit
manouche française voisine membre de la
famille rien le gêne après je pense que
Victor comme moi on aime une littérature
du du coup de point du coup de marteau
sur la tête comme disait Kafka hein donc
du choc pour pour avancer en tant que
lecteur pour qu'à la fin de la lecture
je sois un peu différent mais je pense
pense qu'ussi on aime une lecture qui
nous qui nous met pas dans le sens du
poil ça sert à rien pour moi de lire un
un un ouvrage qui me conforme dans mes
idées qui me conforte dans mes idées ça
sert à rien donc voilà c'est c'est des
c'est de la littérature voilà qui qui
les Allemands disaient stoppelstein
c'est-à-dire voilà on on se heurte à à
un pavé et et on se demande mais
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ici VO c'est un peu d'ailleurs le le
statut de Camille c'est que le visage de
Camille devient justement ce visage qui
est totalementé je vais vous faire non
pas un quiz mais vous demander de
choisir avant que nous procédions au
coup de cœur puisque vous êtes tous les
deux des amoureux de littérature mais
aussi de
cinéma je vais vous citer des des des
des tout à l'heure j'évoquéis ce corsais
bon on pourrait aussi parler d'Orange
mécanique on pourrait parler d'une série
qui passe actuellement qui est d'une
effrayante violence qui s'appelle Gangs
of London on pourrait parler dans le
rôle de l'histoire les années de
Visconti on pourrait parler des rapports
qui existent justement entre une
certaine forme violence et la sexualité
avec toute l'œuvre de kubric hein que ce
soit Awa SHUT ou les films sur la guerre
on pourrait parler d'irréversible de
Gaspar Noé on pourrait parler de portier
de nuit de Liliana Cavani on pourrait
parler des diaboliques de clouso on
pourrait parler de Tarantino on pourrait
parler vous avez travaillé en Asie de
johno ou de John wo au fond qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont apporté tous ces gens en
installant des chefs-dœuvres à cette
limite entre l'acceptable et le non
acceptable Denis c'est difficile de dire
c'est c'est ils ont mis une une forme et
des images aujourd'hui c'est impossible
ouais pas un moral d'aujourd'hui parti
demi c'est impossible ouais c'est
impossible et certains viscontis sont
impossibles aussi donc euh effectivement
heureusement qu'il y a eu ces ces ces
imagesl qui nous ont façonné évidemment
ouais
ouais tout à l'heure il parlait de de
grander vous romancier et cinéaste
est-ce qu'il y a une figure qui est
fondamentale
euh j'en suis sûr il y en a plusieurs le
le si je parle de dans mon cas personnel
parce que en fait on écrit sur son
enfance voilà non mais on écrit sur son
enfance et et et je ENF le le matériaux
principal c'est flanerie Conor qui
disait si vous avez survécu à votre
enfance vous vous vous avez de quoi
devenir romancier et et c'est vrai que
en ce qui me concerne je me rappelle
dans mon enfance de de réaction de mes
parents à la sortie de la Combe Lucien
et ça c'est vraiment un croissement de
Louis m mais sur un un un scénario un
texte de Modiano et donc il y a un
croisement là qui est vraiment très
intéressant qui se retrouve à mon avis
dans le roman merci à tous les deux je
recommande donc chaleureusement et toute
la la la rédaction de bonheur des livres
le livre de Victor dumot
acide le voici qui est publié aux
éditions bouquin et je je me tort
tellement j'ai été marqué par cette
lecture et Denis dercour évre che de
Noël je me tort aussi la violence qui
provient de l'histoire et la violence
qui provient du monde contemporain vous
étiez fait pour vous rencontrer euh
quelques recommandation some boys euh
chez bouquin décidément bouquin est
partout alors vous savez qu' va sortir
un nouvel album des Rolling Stones
someby est une biographie vraiment revue
des Stones mais l'intérêt c'est que
c'est une biographie critique voire très
critique lingstone notamment à partir
des années 80 c'est signé par Louis
bsquet et ça vaut vraiment le coup
d'être lu euh Dimitri kchelov vie et
mort de Vernon Sullivan tout à l'heure
je parlais de Boris Vian Vernon Sullivan
c'est le nom ou plutôt le surnom euh par
lequel borision a écrit vous savez ces
romans policiers j' craché sur vos
tombes et des autres ce qui est émouvant
dans la façon
dont kchelof évoque la personnalité de
Boris Vian c'est qu'en fait sur le
moment celui qui était l'amite sars
celui qui était un musicien de jazz
assez formidable et bien il a connu
l'échec justement de des romans auquels
il tenait à savoir justement L'écume des
jours ou l'automne à Pékin et en
revanche un succès pour ceux qui
fabriquaient d'une manière totalement
artificielle donc c'est cette tension
qui est bien retranscrive dans ce livre
un monument euh nous parlions de la
violence nous parlions de dostoyevski
c'est une autre version de la violence
vous connaissez l'un et l'autre les
cahiers de l'Erne euh Victor voici les
cahiers de l'Erne consacrés à Vladimir
Nabokov l'auteur de Lolita je cite
l'imagination des fertile que
lorsqu'elle est futile voici donc ce
géant de la littérature je ne pe
m'empêcher de vous
l'offrir vous savez que cette revue
enfin c'est c'est le fondamental de la
littérature et j'ajouteraiis d'ailleurs
veranbokov l'ouragan Lolita car elle a
écrit donc en 58 et 59 le journal qui
accompagnait donc l'écriture de c'est
totalement inédit voici et je vais donc
l'offrir à Denis dercour il faut un peu
de désinvolture c'est justement l'une
des plumes du figaron les plus
brillantes qui écrit sur la désinvolture
c'est un recueil de nouvell qui
s'appelle tout simplement une certaine
désinvolture c'est Bertrand de
Saint-Vincent publié aux éditions du
Rocher voici nos recommandations merci à
tous les deux d'être venus nous étions
ravis de vous proposer cette émission au
bonheur des livres le titre est tout un
programme ciao et la semaine prochaine
ou plutôt à
[Musique]
bientôt